the missiles that screamed across
Ukrainian skies on October the 10th
weren't just an attack
[Music]
they were an announcement
the new phase in the war total
bombardment of Ukraine's energy
infrastructure plunging Millions Into
Darkness and into cold
new NASA satellite imagery shared
exclusively with Sky News shows the
lights in Ukraine going out
but people are fighting day and night to
get them back on
[Music]
over the last week Ukraine has seen yet
another bombardment from Russia in just
one day Kiev faced 70 missiles
it was one of the most significant
attacks to be launched on the Ukrainian
Capital since the War Began in February
all her and her husband Ivan's house was
hit in a drone strike
but also yes
on
the country's energy operator
temporarily announced a state of
emergency as the attacks cut Nationwide
energy consumption by more than 50
percent
this is the high voltage Ukrainian
energy grid is the system of energy
highways which transports electricity
around the country it connects to a
wider network of lower voltage cables
the A and B roads of the network that
take energy into people's homes
all of that is fed by nuclear
hydroelectric and coal and gas-fired
power plants amongst others across the
country
Russia had been sporadically targeting
this system in the earlier stages of the
war but on October the 10th the attacks
intensified marking a new phase
at least 20 attacks were reported that
day with Kiev seeing several strikes
power stations were hit including a
number of thermal power plants powered
by coal and gas
this chart shows the effects of the
October the 10th attacks with output
dropping from thermal plants in the
aftermath of the damage a closer look at
one of these attacks shows that the
Russians aren't just targeting the power
plants they're focusing on the
vulnerable equipment which connects them
to the grid
high voltage cables run from the plant
through a substation which contains
Transformers
these Transformers are vulnerable as
they're exposed to the open air and full
of Highly flammable cooling oil
it's part of a wider trend of Russia
targeting Transformers these points Mark
some of the attacks against them which
have come in waves since October the
10th
to find out more we spoke to antonina
and Tosha from dtec a Ukrainian Energy
company based in Kiev she told me about
the wider situation and her morning to
be honest I woke up at 6am this morning
because of the blast right
right
at my window when Russians are attacking
um Ukraine Spar systems facilities they
do it in a very um let's say
sophisticated way because they don't
Target the generating facilities
themselves they target the um
transitioning facilities so we end up in
a situation when we can produce
electricity but we have no opportunity
to
um transmit it to the households these
images from NASA satellites shared
exclusively with Sky News show how the
lights have gone out across Ukraine
these high resolution images show
nighttime lights over Kiev in January
before the war started the capital went
dark following Russia's Invasion as
Keith came under direct assault
and Russia's recent attacks on Ukraine's
energy grid have caused light levels to
drop even lower
many Suburban areas have gone almost
entirely dark either as a result of
being cut off from the Grid or because
National Grid operators have prioritized
maintaining power to Central Kiev
Sky News analysis of the satellite data
found that two months after the attacks
some outer suburbs are still 80 percent
dimmer than they were in September we
can map that data to show the difference
decreases in light levels are marked in
red increases in pink the average
Ukrainian City saw its lights dim by
half one such city was Lev far from the
war's front lines
a close analysis of satellite imagery
from the attacks on Lev suggests a
deliberate targeting of the city's
energy infrastructure on October the
10th Russia attacked the Transformer
outside burst in power station which
supplies energy to much of leviv
on the same day Russia also targeted
that Echidna Transformer which allows
bushton's electricity to enter Ukraine's
ultra high voltage cross-country grid
three other high voltage Transformers
around Lev were also attacked during the
same wave in a clear attempt to
overwhelm the city's grid
for engineers at Ukrainian power
companies like dtec it is a Relentless
test of their speed and creativity
but they also need help and they've
appealed to the International Community
for Energy Solutions to help them get
through this winter and the next one
that's what they're getting here at a
matchmaking event in Manchester it's
trying to pair British manufacturers and
what they can offer with what Ukraine
needs we're really looking forward to
the discussions which will take place
it's a long way from Kiev the
conversations here have and will
translate into direct action on the
ground with the Ukrainian government
then energy operators speaking directly
to companies
is the chief executive of the energy
Industry Council the industry
Association for British energy
manufacturers
he says that Ukraine's Soviet
infrastructure makes the challenge
harder the engineering drawings
associated with those parts and the
supply chains associated with those
parts are not available to EU or UK
companies so they're going to have to be
either reverse engineered and that will
you know to get their parts and to get
them designed and get them to meet the
specification and supplied probably a
year
one of those companies is Wilson Power
Solutions they're based in leads and
make exactly the sort of large
Transformers that Ukraine so desperately
needs
the problem is that it takes at least 11
months to make one so decisions need to
be made now it's absolutely fair to say
that the Russians are aware that the
infrastructure that they're destroying
is on a long lead time
and unless we act now we we won't have
those Solutions a year or 18 months down
the line but equally then
as British manufacturing and British
supply chain we can look at what
potential Solutions we can offer and to
our Ukrainian colleagues
to try and find short-term fixes to that
as well
as important as the long-term energy
Warriors Ukraine must survive this
winter first it's set up tents like this
one called invincibility centers places
where heat and electricity is guaranteed
where people can warm their bodies and
charge their phones there is no way
Russia can plunge a Ukraine into total
cold and a Darkness throughout this
winter we have already actually started
the countdown because we do realize that
we have only only 180 in 108 days left
until this winter is over and then
we get
one but such a gigantic step closer to
Victory because this winter is the last
thing that Russia's dictator named
putting has at stake and he will never
succeed
in the meantime they are taking the
smaller steps too
some underground trains started running
in Kiev this week for the first time in
nine months of War thanks to managing
the energy grid smartly
the stations still serve as bomb
shelters
but just getting on the tube is a
glimpse of the routine normal life which
ukrainians hope awaits once winter is
over and the power is on Tom Cheshire
Sky News